I'm asked often it is the government
doing enough what is the practice
actually going to do me where's the role
of each and service and I am concerned
that if the government is doing it all
then it actually crowds out some of the
initiative of people who will make a
difference that's data you need to make
it easy to make a difference so when
folks want to help they have a way of
helping I think one of the most
important things that this whole service
movement is going to create is an
expectation among kids going through
high school that when they're done
they're going to spend a year serving
the nation whether it's the military or
are going to old H facilities and making
life fun for people who have given their
life to this nation or playing a role in
educating the next generation of kids
about their bodies or some other facet
of their life that they don't know
enough about and by making that an
expectation rather than something novel
and unique we're going to change the
culture of volunteers in service in
America